Overall, sir,
your weapon will--
Zane, Chris, congratulations.
You boys have made it
into the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the Revolutionary
War sergeant spontoone.
Mhmm.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
[heavy metal music]
ZANE: We're back in
Waxhaw, and I have
to make a Sergeant spontoone.
I decided to use 5160
for the blade steel
because it is relatively
easy to heat treat
but also holds up very
well when under duress.
My main goal is to elongate
this piece of steel that
will eventually
become the blade so
that it meets the requirements.
Yeah, it's a slow
press, but it's OK.
CHRIS: I'm back
in my home forge.
I'm ready to get started.
I'm excited.
I'm going to build
a Damascus billet.
I'm going to try to get
as many layers as I can.
I think it'll impress the
judges and hopefully hold
up really well on the tests.
I got my main billet cleaned up.
I'm going to cut it and restack
it, get it to the size I need,
and then I can hopefully start
getting the point shaped out.
Day two, I'm going to
be working on the socket,
getting that more
fit and finished.
I've also going to grind and
hopefully heat treat my blade.
For the heat treat, I'm going to
be using this oven right here.
It works really well
with temperature control.
I can keep my blade
exactly the temperature
that I want it for
how long I want it.
I'm nervous that my heat
treat is not going to go well.
I could have the blade snap.
I could have it warp.
I could have it just
not harden at all.
I don't hear any tinking
sound, so that's good.
Tinks are usually cracks.
And it's hard, and
I am so excited.
Woo!
That was scary.
CHRIS: Yesterday I got the
crossguard and the spear
to shape.
The crossguard being a separate
piece is a concern of mine.
I am going to have
to forge weld that
for structural-integrity
reasons.
Probably going to get into some
welding with the MIG welder
just to reinforce everything
and, hopefully, after that,
get it ready for a heat treat.
Day three is here.
I plan on finishing
out my blade,
and then I am going to weld my
tang and my guard to my socket.
That's pretty good.
CHRIS: It's day for
on my spontoone build.
The first thing I got to do
today is get the haft cut out
and the shape down.
I layered the wood up.
Hopefully the difference
in grain structure
will help in strengthness
and flexibility.
I left it sort of octagonal.
I think it will give
a little better grip.
Now it's time to
get my haft attached
to my spontoone spearhead.
It was a hell of a build.
I'm tired.
I'm sore.
I think it looks awesome.
I cut one.
I'm good.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
And I will take
your weapon, deliver
some thrusts and slashes
on this wild-boar carcass.
Zane, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Ready as I'll ever be.
[suspenseful music]
[heavy metal music]
All right, Zane, let's
talk about your weapon here.
First up, your tip is
really made to thrust.
It punctures really deep
when I'm thrusting with it,
but I can move with this weapon.
You have a good balance here.
The edge here is sharp.
As you can see, those are
very, very deep, sharp cuts.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you, Doug.
All right, Chris,
it's your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[heavy metal music]
All right, Chris, let's
talk about your weapon here.
What I love about this
is when you're thrusting,
I can feel the weight
in front and crunch ribs
as it's penetrating.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, gentlemen, say
hello to my little friend.
To test the strength and
durability of your blade,
we're going to be firing
out of our air cannon
here into that wooden wall.
All right, Zane,
you're up first.
This thing is going to
launch my spontoone, my baby,
at a wall of wood.
I'm an odd mixture between
excited and nervous right now.
In, 3, 2, 1, fire.
All right, Zane,
nothing came apart.
It still has the edge
it started out with.
All in all, good job.
Thank you.
CHRIS: Nice job.
All right, Chris, you're up.
Firing in 3, 2, 1.
Fire.
CHRIS: Wow.
Good job, Chris.
OK, your weapon went right
in between those boards,
so it actually took all the
impact up here on these lugs.
Everything's still
straight, still sharp.
I really like that
pattern you got on there.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
That is nice.
[suspenseful music]
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the sharpness test,
the redcoat stab and slice.
To test the sharpness of your
edge, I will take your weapon
and slash stab
across this redcoat.
Zane, you're up first.
Let's do it.
[heavy metal music]
All right, Zane,
your edges are sharp.
On the swing of
that, it does cut.
But what I do find
here is a little bit
of a glinting at your tip.
It catches on my nails.
It rolled a little bit
right there at your tip.
But otherwise, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Chris, your turn.
Let's do this.
Things have actually been
really even between Zane and I.
I just hope my spontoone,
it's strong and sharp enough.
This is it.
[suspenseful music]
[heavy metal music]
All right, Chris, this is
a very razor-sharp blade.
Every slash and
thrust was a deep cut.
I do not see any
damage to your edge.
Overall, sir, this
weapon will cut.
Thank you.
Zane, Chris, you guys
have done fantastic work
on these finale weapons,
but there can only
be one "Forged in
Fire" champion,
and the judges have made
their final decision.
And that "Forged in
Fire" champion is Chris.
Congratulations.
You are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Congratulations, man.
Zane, unfortunately
your weapon
took some damage during the
sharpness test which affected
the efficacy of your cuts.
For that reason, I'd like to
invite you to shake my hand,
shake your judges' hands, and
then please leave the forge.
Came on, my friend.
--to meet you guys.
Good job, brother.
I did not win, but that's OK.
It's a great weapon.
I came here to
prove that I was
able to compete with
some of the big dogs,
and I think I made my point.
I hope that I'll be able to
keep improving upon my craft
and just get better and better.
Chris, you crafted
a better weapon
that held up through the tests.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Come over here and
shake our heads.
Absolutely.
CHRIS: I just became
"Forged in Fire" champion.
[laughs] That's crazy.
I'm, like, turning
inside out right now.
I got the bragging rights, man.
I can just keep moving ahead,
keep doing what I'm doing.
[heavy metal music]